[Música]
y
el presidente de argentina alberto
fernández nombró a sergio massa como
super ministro de economía en una
reorganización que absorberá las
carteras de desarrollo productivo y
agricultura esto tras la renuncia de
silvina batakis que estuvo 24 días en el
cargo el remisión se produce en medio de
la fuerte crisis económica que golpea al
país tenemos reporte desde buenos aires
colombia y venezuela restablecerán
relaciones diplomáticas rotas desde 2019
la decisión se producirá tras la
posesión del gobierno de gustavo petro
el 7 de agosto en bogotá y fue anunciada
tras una reunión entre el designado
canciller colombiano álvaro leyva y su
homólogo venezolano carlos faría en el
estado de táchira
el presidente de perú pedro castillo
cumplió un año en el poder y defendió su
mandato ante el congreso pese a que se
trata de un periodo marcado por las
polémicas la inestabilidad política
cinco investigaciones preliminares en su
contra abiertas por la fiscalía y un
alto índice de desaprobación
bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy valentina torre sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
argentina porque la crisis que golpea el
país causó un nuevo remezón político el
presidente alberto fernández nombró a
sergio massa como nuevo superministro de
economía lo que significa que esa
oficina absorberá a los ministerios de
desarrollo productivo y agricultura esto
luego de la renuncia de silvina batakis
quien sólo estuvo 24 días al frente del
cargo y que ahora dirigirá el banco
nación de argentina previamente natal yo
que soy corresponsal de france 24 en
buenos aires nos explicó quién es sergio
massa como lo ven los argentinos y
porqué fernández lo nombró super
ministro
ahora que te algunas noches sergio massa
es una figura perenne de las últimas
décadas de la política argentina comenzó
en un partido liberal de derecha en su
juventud la ucedé luego se pasó al
peronismo desde entonces está en el
peronismo fue el jefe de gabinete de
cristina fernández de kirchner la actual
vicepresidenta cuando ella fue
presidenta y sucedió casualmente en el
cargo al que ahora es el presidente
alberto fernández que también había sido
jefe de gabinete cristina fernández de
kirchner luego sergio massa seguido
desarrollando su carrera que en un
momento fundó un partido se dentro del
peronismo se independizó si se quiere se
lanzó a la presidencia en 2015 nos llegó
quedó tercero pero siempre tuvo estas
aspiraciones de poder unas aspiraciones
de poder que lo colocaron en un lugar
privilegiado dentro de la coalición de
gobierno del frente de todos hoy que por
ahora se ve en su cabeza a alberto
fernández pero en la que tiene muchísimo
poder la ex presidente de actual
vicepresidenta cristina fernández y
también mucho poder
sergio massa que hasta ahora por ahora
hasta la semana que viene cuando termine
de definir esa situación era presidente
de la cámara de diputados y ahora
entrará s ministerio por estos
movimientos que ha tenido históricamente
sergio massa cercanías y alejamientos
algunos en la sociedad argentina lo ven
como una figura cambiante que cambia de
posición y de alianzas pero a la vez es
un hombre que dialoga con todos y que
tiene muchos vínculos en la política con
empresarios con factores de poder en el
país y hay una expectativa en ese
sentido de que tal vez con eso pueda
conseguir generar expectativas positivas
y tranquilizar un poco la muy muy
convulsionada economía de la argentina
en otras noticias los cancilleres de
colombia y venezuela se reunieron en la
ciudad de san cristóbal en venezuela- y
acordaron una normalización de las
relaciones diplomáticas un plan que
entrará en vigor según lo previsto a
partir del 7 de agosto cuando gustavo
petro asuma como nuevo presidente de
colombia ambos países acordaron nombrar
a sus respectivos embajadores colombia
venezuela son países hermanos e
históricos y rompieron sus relaciones en
2019 cuando el saliente presidente iván
duque reconoció a juan guaidó como
presidente legítimo de venezuela
una firma que pone fin a años de
enemistad el canciller de venezuela
carlos faría y el canciller designado de
colombia álvaro leyva acordaron
normalizar relaciones binacionales desde
el 7 de agosto
inspirados en la gesta histórica del
libertador simón bolívar han reafirmado
los lazos históricos de hermandad
complementariedad y cooperación que unen
a nuestros pueblos la reunión fue en
venezuela y el canciller local también
habló de esta nueva fase
hemos acordado él
establecimiento una vez que llegue ese
momento por supuesto
inmediato restablecer a los
embajadores que van a representar a
nuestros países tras su victoria en los
comicios de junio el presidente electo
de colombia gustavo petro se puso en
contacto de inmediato con el presidente
venezolano nicolás madura
una apuesta diplomática contraria a la
de la administración precedente de iván
duque en 2019 rompieron relaciones
después de estas declaraciones quiero
expresar que colombia
reconoce a juan guaidó como presidente
de venezuela y acompaña este proceso de
transición hacia la democracia para que
el pueblo venezolano se libere de la
dictadura la normalización también
traerá la promesa de la reapertura de la
frontera de 2.219 kilómetros que
comparten ambos países está cerrada a
los vehículos desde 2015 desde entonces
el intercambio comercial se redujo un 70
por ciento
pedro castillo cumplió un año como
presidente de perú un gobierno marcado
por las denuncias de corrupción cinco
investigaciones preliminares en su
contra cuatro de ellas a por hechos
ocurridos durante su gestión dos
mociones de vacancia como lo dicta la
constitución peruana el mandatario dio
un discurso de casi dos horas para
rendir cuentas de su gestión en donde
destacó avances en infraestructura
planes sociales y acuerdos comerciales
en el exterior sin embargo la
desaprobación de su gestión supera el 70
por ciento
cercado el presidente peruano pedro
castillo defendió su gestión y denunció
campaña para destituirlo durante su
discurso a la nación en el congreso por
la conmemoración de la independencia de
perú fecha en la que juramento en el
cargo hace un año
desestabilizan y reclaman la vacancia
no por falta de resultados o por
inexistentes imputaciones que nunca
probarán sino por defender sus intereses
privados y por ende por evitar los
cambios que mi gobierno se empeñan en
cumplir el mandatario se ha enfrentado a
dos mociones de vacancia y cuenta con
cinco investigaciones fiscales en
proceso cuatro de ellas por hechos
ocurridos durante su gestión pero
castillo desmiente todo tipo de
acusaciones porque a los medios
empeñados en desestabilizar el gobierno
no les interesa difundir los logros sólo
se emiten mentiras y noticias falsas de
pedro castillo solo se emiten esas cosas
acusado de corrupción sin ninguna prueba
se van a cansar de buscar las pruebas
porque no la van a encontrar
sin embargo las confesiones de su ex
secretario de presidencia y hombre de
confianza
bruno pacheco apuntan directamente al
mandatario y a su entorno pero esto no
es lo único que preocupa el pueblo
peruano y a la oposición
líder de izquierda ha incumplido 51
promesas entre ellas renunciar a el
sueldo presidencial y a la pensión
vitalicia asignar el 10% del pib a la
educación fortalecer 4.000 centros de
salud entre otras y ha tenido 59
ministros en un año una cifra que da
cuenta de la inestabilidad al interior
del ejecutivo debo admitir que hemos
cometido errores con algunas
designaciones así como brindar confianza
a quienes se aprovecharon y burlaron de
ella aunque extendió su mano a la
oposición para trabajar juntos por el
bien del pueblo su mensaje finalizó de
manera accidentada
entre tanto cientos de personas
marcharon en lima la capital a favor y
en contra del presidente algunos
pidiendo el cierre del congreso y otros
su renuncia
la alcaldesa de la ciudad de san
francisco decretó el estado de
emergencia a causa del creciente número
de casos de viruela del mono la
declaración que entra en vigencia el
lunes se produce cuando se han reportado
261 casos de los cerca de 800 que tiene
el estado de california las casas
nacionales de vacunas ha dado lugar a
que las personas esperen en filas
durante horas para recibir dosis escasas
para que quede claro el mensaje es que
si hubiera otra comunidad que se viera
afectada de manera desproporcionada por
la viruela del mono de la forma en la
que se ha visto afectada a la comunidad
gay todo el país se levantaría en armas
así que no tratemos a esta comunidad de
manera diferente a nosotros hagamos lo
que necesitamos para obtener las vacunas
y obtener el tratamiento y llevar los
recursos a las ciudades que más lo
necesitan en guetos resort
disneyland emaús se enfrentó con él y
san francisco claramente según los datos
la ciudad que más lo necesita así que
nuestra declaración de emergencia es
para hacer sonar la alarma y dejar muy
claro necesitamos desesperadamente más
vacunas más tratamientos para apoyar a
las personas de nuestra ciudad en
atención médica como cualquier otra
persona
finalizamos en nueva york donde la casa
sotheby's subastó el esqueleto de un
dinosaurio gordo sauros que habitaba la
tierra hace 77 millones de años el fósil
se vendió por 6,1 millones de dólares y
mide casi 3 metros de alto y más de 6
metros y medio de largo el esqueleto fue
hallado en el estado estadounidense de
montana en 2018
así concluimos esta emisión de noticias
quédense con nosotros que volvemos en
breve
[Música]